nicolas sarkozy répondra quelques mètres
plus loin à l'entrée du centre
hospitalier de dunkerque peut pas
continuer les jeunes et des moyens le
crucial
les fûts remet à plus tard la capsule
gallière l'organisation de cette can il
faut prendre conscience qu'il ya
beaucoup de douleur
beaucoup se sentent personnellement je
supporte tout ça mérite de la
considération la considération à la fois
morale personnelle et financière
il veut fusionner des établissements
changer des services favoriser
l'autonomie mais juré sans rien faire
mais pour le démontrer il a choisi le
nord pas de calais ou tissu social
fragile une région déficit de personnel
qui connaît l'une des plus forte
surmortalité de france puis au service
des dialyses il parle aux patients je
suis chez vous savez la chance aussi
courage qu'on a
ça qui est important la chanson vrai la
chercher plus tard à l'hôpital maritime
de zuydcoote
ils visitent l'unité de soins palliatifs
une véritable gêne family a parlé de la
fin de vie mon épouse est partie à 33
ans il est resté huit mois j'espère
qu'il ya d'autres personnes qui pourront
bénéficier je dirais de place en réponse
nicolas sarkozy fait la seule annonce
concrète du jour j'ai demandé à la
ministre réfléchir à ce qu'on puisse
doubler les unités de soins palliatifs
parce que c'est pas un luxe c'est un
droit ça s'appelle le droit à la dignité
puis il aborde un sujet sensible
l'évolution de la loi sur l'euthanasie
il veut un débat national sur ce tabou
qui divise sa majorité